[Musique]
bonjour je suis n'avaient pas 40 30 ans
et je suis gironde a souhaité savoir et
savoir faire
donc j'ai un instant de soutien scolaire
et assure des formations pour adultes
la pâtisserie soutien scolaire c'est
pour les enfants de l'école primaire
jusqu'au collège obtenu par petits
groupes de trois ou quatre enfants maxi
un maximum pour être beaucoup plus
efficace de travail à protéger beaucoup
plus de personnaliser aux enfants alors
notre deuxième partie de sa formation
aux adultes
on travaille avec le cadre du deal avec
le pôle emploi et les missions locales
pour aider la population sur les remises
à niveau en français en mathématiques
d'une initiation à l'informatique
on a aussi beaucoup de personnes âgées
qui viennent nous voir pour s'initier à
l'informatique
alors je concours de la théorie prix du
jury car je pense qui a plu au jury
c'est ma motivation
à la base j'étais dans la branche
comptabilité du coup j'ai dû arrêter mes
études pour diverses raisons
je suis devenu assistant d'éducation est
en contact des élèves dans le collège
des professeurs ça m'a donné la fibre de
pouvoir enseigner
j'ai repris mes études en licence de
sciences de l'éducation puis un master
recherche à l'espé de la réunion qui m'a
amené à ouvrir mon sens de souhaiter
scolaire un an plus tard alors j'étais
demandeur d'emploi je suis parti voir la
chambre de commerce et avec un de la
conseiller à la maison de l'entreprise
j'ai pu monter mon dossier de création
d'entreprise ayant même temps parallèle
un dossier un dossier de subvention le
tage de tremplin d'activité gel devenir
chef d'entreprise m'a permis de
conjuguer deux choses qui me tenait
vraiment à coeur
l'enseignement et d'entrepreneuriat je
vais au début on un peu peur de se
lancer mais avec de l'investissement on
ne peut que réussir je mérite de gagner
le challenge des créateurs
car avant c'était moi qui était dans le
besoin et grâce
à la création de mon entreprise j'ai
donc maintenant les gens passant du plus
jeune aux salariés et aux personnes
âgées
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle turbé limagne j'ai
32 ans et je suis gérante du salon la
prime annuelle
ça fait un an que j'ai ouvert le salon
marc-emmanuel avec mon associé et
mathieu le cros on a voulu ouvrir dans
notre quartier pour valoriser et
dynamiser ce quartier qui est quand même
défavorisés mais en plein développement
ce qui me tenait à coeur aussi c'est
d'apporter mon expérience et mon savoir
faire aux personnes du quartier c'est à
dire à nathalie qui aujourd'hui apprend
si c'est au salon et qui habite dans le
quartier talent beau et aussi
prochainement prendre aussi
quelqu'un un garçon pour le côté homme
aussi quelqu'un qui fait partie du
quartier
sur 126 candidats j'ai été retenu sur le
prix du jury
aujourd'hui c'est une grande fierté pour
moi puisque les jurys ont vu ma
motivation et surtout mes ambitions
j'ai travaillé dans plusieurs salons
dont là j'étais responsable
j'ai arrêté pendant un petit moment pour
des raisons personnelles
quand j'ai voulu créer mon entreprise je
suis passé par l'anpe
la boutique de gestion qui m'a aiguillé
sur le tâches ou là j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir 8000 euros aujourd'hui ce qui
m'apporte la position de chef
d'entreprise sait déjà que je suis
indépendant moi je préfère donner la
chance aux personnes qui n'ont peut-être
pas d'expérience mais au moins je peux
les former à ma façon et leur donner la
chance d'avoir un métier et un avenir
pour un premier salon franchement j'en
suis fier pourquoi pas demain voire une
chaîne
au nombre du salon marc emmanuel je vais
gagner le challenge des créateurs
puisque je suis très dynamique très
ambitieuse envie surtout de réussir
transmettre mon savoir faire et dès
l'insertion des jeunes du quartier
[Musique]